are they classified are they just today
the judge is declaring them classified
but this is the federal filing so I
won't show the classified doctors I'll
show the federal filing in here uh
that's now been put up by uh
a bunch of even mainstream
journalists like Julie Kelly uh it says
right here edit out they were present
that the feds were there leading the
group and then it describes in one line
uh here and I guess the crew could
probably pull this up where they say
here it is
Miller's Communications is another agent
who states the agent's FBI boss assigned
to 338 items of evidence I had to
destroy why would they want to do that
destroying evidence is a felony why
would they want to destroy the evidence
wouldn't they want more evidence because
they were leading it of course